Hey Youtubers it's Charlie! This is going
to be my flash trailer breakdown the big thing
is it's going to be a zoom and Doctor light
episode but not the Doctor light you are expecting
a real quick reminder the reverse flash ring
giveaway for this week is still going on all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video the episode
is titled darkness and light so of course
it's going to be the Doctor light episode
it's easier use her powers here I'm I'm assuming
there can be a slightly to them down version
of what they are in the comics her powers
defined as photo kinesis and she actually
the interesting thing about how she got her
powers in the comics is that during crisis
on infinite earths as they were nearing the
final battle the monitor wanted to raise a
new champion to help fight the anti-moderator
so he basically uses his powers to activate
her as a new champion of earth most you're
probably familiar with Arthur light the crazy
scientists that Cisco mentioned on season
two of arrow that was that was like a long
time ago now the he's does like gun he has
some gear hidden in the basement of star labs
but the really cool thing that the TV show
is changing about the character is that it's
going to be the earth two version of Linda
Park is not crazy that's freaking awesome
we also learn in the trailer that Harrison
wells is responsible for creating zoom either
metaphorically or through an accident or through
his version of the particle accelerator explosion
so right off the bat he's not zoom but I don't
think most of us thought that he was either
identity the likely candidates are some of
the good characters now some of the good speedsters
that he says is really important thing about
zoom poisoning his earth he's going to do
the same thing to your earth so it sounds
like earth two is kind of like a crime syndicate
earth we know zoom has been throwing matters
at Barry trying to get rid of them so that
he is the only speedster left so that no one
select to challenge him sweeter all these
evil earth two characters are compelled to
fight for him or they are in league with him
I think what's going on is that they're just
more afraid of zoom than they are everyone
else so they'll just do whatever he says that's
what I think Harrison wells is talking about
when he said zoom poisoned his earth in that
he's bent all the Meadows to his will that
either you can serve me or you can die so
that really does sound like crime syndicate
which is actually earth three in the the DC
multi-verse but remember the TV universe is
earth two as far as I can tell though a seeing
Earth to Linda Park is Doctor light is our
first instance of singing evil version of
in Earth one character like we haven't seen
any of these main characters evil twins from
earth two yet if if they are able I'm assuming
that some of them are probably still good
just at the writers are using Earth to the
surface most of the new villains 940 done
a Doctor light video for the flash whenever
they they announced that they were going to
bring her on the show so I'll put a link that
in the description of the comic book version
of the character's name is Kimyo Hoshi she
said she actually it is certain point in the
comics chance of having to battle it out with
Arthur light is like how dare you take my
mantle so hopefully the future season will
get to see like evil earth to Linda Park Doctor
light battle it out with Arthur light from
Earth one is much as people complain what
things can change from the comics I feel like
this is going to be really awesome this take
on the character just getting a chance to
see one of the characters that we love be
evil is way more fun than doing Arthur light
plus if you're familiar with the Arthur like
character you know how he is kind of problematic
he is one of the worst human beings the multi-verse
but just to talk a little bit more about zoom
now that we've seen his costume like in an
a much more close up way it looks like the
black racers suit of the black racer is two
different characters is the black costume
flash which is just like kind of an aspect
of death for speedsters and then there's the
new gods version of the black racer which
is a different character now if you been reading
Geoff Johnson Darkside war right now it is
just as the title these writing right now
it's actually really bad ass he should check
it out but the she combines the Barry Allen
flash with the new gods version of the black
racer to create a new gods black flash and
it looks on awful lot like zoom on the TV
show so just theory craft as you will I don't
think that is the TV shows doing I mean this
is not can be the new gods but it just is
really interesting the imagery this evokes
really I think the biggest reason that they
chose the black costume in the blue lightning
is to differentiate zoom from Prof. zoom in
a bar Thawne last season just because there
still people that I I see in the comments
who are confused about the difference between
zoom in Prof. zoom their two different characters
that are part of the reverse flash family
so you have the flash family in your the reverse
flash family although I don't think the reverse
flash is would think of themselves as family
the TV show never actually called a LaVar
Thawne Prof. zoom last year so I think a lot
of TV show only people are little confused
about that don't worry whenever were talking
about zoom were talking about this black costume
zoom but just to run down the list of possibilities
I feel like it's still growing like you can
still be a number of characters right now
the most interesting would be Jon Wesley Shipp
would be Barry's dad if he were the reverse
flash that be like a twisted version of Thomas
Wayne from flashpoint whereby Bruce Wayne
died as a child so Thomas Wayne his father
became Batman resist evil crazy version of
Batman that is earth two Wally West even more
interesting than that would be Joe West or
Iris West be crazy a virus West was zoom I
don't think she is and you have evil version
of Barry which I'd I think is a little too
obvious you have evil version of Patty which
is a little bit more likely little bit more
interesting and then you have the Edward Clariss
reverse flash who was the reverse flash during
Jay Garrick's time in the comics during the
Golden age is much as this is a show about
Barry Allen's journey in all the other characters
are just passing through it I do think that
they're going to do more Jay Garrick arrow
stuff if you can bring Jay Garrick on the
show you might as well bring some of his characters
long for the right to so given that we know
Tony Todd is doing the voice in the end the
way the zoom talks that we've heard them talk
who do you think this character is I still
think that it's a male character and I'm slowly
drifting away from it being Barry just because
Barry doesn't talk with that inflection even
if you were being evil he wouldn't talk like
that just the way his accent works remember
they're going to the Darth Vader thing where
you have a different actor doing the voice
in this scary costume but you don't know who's
underneath it if you ever wanted the best
deconstruction of why it's a bad thing that
there is a white actor underneath the black
costume just wants like the first five minutes
of chasing Amy it is there's a the greatest
deconstruction of Star Wars ever and that
is it selected the first 10 minutes of that
movie episode seven is going to be one gorilla
Grodd comes back the time of the episode is
guerrilla warfare so it's going to be awesome
he kidnaps Caitlin Barry has to track him
down and Cisco is supposed to be going on
a date with Hawkgirl so I can only imagine
how that's can and once Hawkman finds out
about it in the description for the episode
it also says that Patty is getting suspicious
that Barry is hiding something from her though
she still has not found out that Barry is
the flash as the episode seven to get height
because it is going to be bananas so what
can happen next is is Doctor who is going
to be tomorrow morning I'll post that video
then I'll do and arrow trailer video for Constantine
that's what I'll do the Q&A and the reverse
flash ring giveaway so white as way for all
that you can click here to watch my Supergirl
trailer video almost more people watched it
on Monday night than watched The Walking Dead
on Sunday night to give you an idea and click
here for this week's Flash episode thank you
so much watching everybody high five and I'll
see you guys tonight